the faster the better that's the motto
of many german drivers for them speed is
freedom
it's a pure adrenaline rush the whole
time like when a plane takes off and
you're pressed back into your seat
it reduces stress and does you good
basically it's a drug a legal drug
but that could soon come to a halt
30 kilometers an hour that's now the
speed limit in more and more german
inner cities like aachen it's a sign of
the times but one that doesn't sit well
with kemah sakh and his brother jem
the two cartooners feel they're being
unfairly targeted
especially for children kids going to
school in the morning it's absolutely
justified
but there are plenty of places where
it's not necessary
also in other zones where the speed
limit is higher than 30.
there you can see it's not just about
the speed limit and safety but rather
let's call it arbitrary just arbitrary
however the city council says imposing
the 30 kilometer per hour limit on major
thoroughfares makes akin safer cleaner
and greener and germany's environment
agency confirms that slowing down
traffic improves air quality
it's just safer for everyone who's
walking around here
but not everyone wants to rethink things
the sound of his car's engine is music
to kama's ears
when it's done this old golf 2 will also
have 300 horsepower overkill at 30
kilometers an hour for kamal and his
friends climate protection isn't a high
priority new management next door in
belgium they drive antique cars around
or diesels which really harm the
environment
eight kilometers away we're not going to
save the planet from that
but marvin krinks wants to save the
climate and says time is running out so
if a 30 kilometer per hour limit helps
he's all for it he's puzzled why many
drivers can't seem to take their foot
off the gas
the rate of compliance is unfortunately
pretty low in akin
i don't know if they're going way too
fast but they certainly aren't abiding
by the rules
there's a collision of interests anyone
who drives a car like this wants to show
off what it can do this nissan gtr has
over 700 horsepower and consumes 21
liters of fuel per 100 kilometers in
city traffic here no one would give us
an interview but kamal shows us how much
fun you can have in such a mean machine
in this video
[Music]
[Applause]
over the years my buddies and i have
worked towards being able to drift right
around a big traffic circle for that you
need power and preferably rear wheel
drive
germany is the only european country
with no general speed limit on highways
drivers like gem fear that imposing a 30
kph limit in cities is the beginning of
the end of speed limit free driving in
germany
safety takes priority but we all know
this isn't just about safety
it's
and for kamal and gem that's more fun
without a general speed limit but
increasingly they're in the minority
most germans are now in favor of more
speed limits for the sake of the climate